[Musik]
oktober 2018 pariser autosalon unter den
neuheiten mehrere elektroautos der neuen
generation sogar die hersteller wie
diesen sektor immer vernachlässigt
hatten sind in einem scheinbar neues
geschäft eingestiegen das ist der kia
nie noch bevor er in norwegen in einem
paradies für elektroautos auf den markt
kam aber er gab es 5000 reservierungen
wir sehen eine vorschau auf den mercedes
eco c ein kompakter suv der premium
kategorie der technologisch der die
präsenz der deutschen marke auf dem
markt markiert
[Musik]
es ist keine mode oder ein trend wissen
sie manchmal entscheidet ein markt von
sich aus sich in richtung elektroauto
industrie zu bewegen wenn die leute
bereit sind autos zu kaufen sollten sie
sie haben
sicherlich ist die zukunft der mobilität
elektrisch wir wissen nur nicht genau
wann jetzt ist es ein des weltmarktes
das elektroauto wird aber erst dann
wichtig wenn es zehn prozent sind
[Musik]
ich stecke ihn aus er
fährt
[Musik]
mama
ok mama fährt von den futuristischen
visionen einer elektrischen zukunft
klären wir in die gegenwart zurück die
gene aus dem tessin sind 657 von
227.000 elektroautos zugelassen das sind
0,2 prozent des fahrzeugbestandes ein
sehr geringer anteil der die nationale
situation widerspiegelt
[Musik]
in mein ressort so haben wir ein problem
mit der umweltverschmutzung also haben
wir ein elektroauto gekauft weil es die
umwelt nicht verschmutzt wir haben ein
reines gewissen vor allem wenn ich an
meinen sohn denke
hallo
in der schweiz gibt es derzeit keine
anreize im tessin sind die die ein
elektroauto fahren oft idealisten die
die umwelt nicht verschmutzen wollen in
einem kanton wo es viel staub und der in
der luft qualitäts statistik immer das
schlusslicht
der tessiner staatsrat will aber in
übereinstimmung mit dem luft-
sanierungsplan subventionen einführen um
die verbreitung von emissionsfreien
autos zu fördern
das wird demnächst auch im parlament
diskutiert
was sind die folgen des umstiegs auf ein
elektroauto wir haben uns mit einigen
autofahrern getroffen die diese
entscheidung bereits getroffen haben
[Musik]
nicola und anna maria mit ihrem sohn
antonio sie haben zwei autos beide
elektrisch das eine ist eigentlich kaum
mehr als ein motor aber seine leistung
hat die familie riva überzeugt dass
benzinauto zu entsorgen mit einer
schnellen internet recherche fanden sie
eine tolle gelegenheit für ein auto in
der deutschsprachigen schweiz
wir haben es zum halben preis gekauft
aber am ende wird er mehr preis den man
für den kauf zahlt durch eine menge
niedriger kosten kompensiert
die versicherung die nummernschilder
benzin selbst
der parkplatz und vor allem auch der
verbrauch und die wartung
um den gebrauchten bmw i3 nach hause zu
bringen erlebte die familie riva die
berühmte autonomie panik denn das auto
kann zumindest auf dem papier etwa 200
kilometer weit fahren bevor es wieder
aufgeladen werden muss aber der rückweg
ist länger trotzdem beschließen sie
loszufahren noch unerfahren kommen sie
an einer nicht funktionierenden säule
ran an den nächsten können sie nicht
aufladen bis sie sich an eine hotel
steckdose anschließen nach einem
zweistündigen halt zeigt die batterie 20
kilometer autonomie an
ich habe immer wieder geguckt wie viele
kilometer ist noch bis zum ausgang des
tunnels waren und wie viele kilometer
autonomie wir noch hatten und die beiden
waren mehr oder weniger gleich wir sind
auf energiesparen umgestiegen und haben
die klimaanlage ausgeschaltet in dem
tunnel ist es heißt und ich habe mir
schon das schlimmste ausgemalt als sind
ganz langsam gefahren um energie zu
sparen und das auto hinter uns hat immer
lichthupe gemacht
aber sagen wir mal er war ein bisschen
aufgeregt werden von den leuten die 60
kilometer die stunde im gotthard fahren
gibt es sowieso eine menge auf halber
strecke wo es anfängt bergab zu gehen
sind wir wie von zauberhand von sechs
kilometern die wir noch hatten auf 18
gekommen
genau durch das loslassen des gaspedals
oder durch das bremsen wird energie
zurückgewonnen
heute nutzt die riva familie alle
möglichkeiten auf haben von der
kostenlosen zu hause mit einer
photovoltaikanlage auf dem dach bis zu
den öffentlichen sollen das überqueren
der grenze ist kein problem mehr heute
fahren sie nach varese wo ihr sohn mini
rugby spielt
für eine lange reise gibt es online
rechner die mit bestimmten angaben wie
der lufttemperatur der entfernung und so
weiter die kosten berechnen wenn man im
durchschnitt 40 kilometer die stunde
fährt kann man diese strecke zurücklegen
bei 80 kilometern pro stunde ist es
natürlich etwas weniger
es ist eine andere art des reisens
früher sind wir von einem punkt a
losgefahren um zu einer probiert zu
kommen jetzt können wir die reise mehr
genießen weil wir vielleicht an einem
ort anhalten den wir nicht kennen
auto aufladen einen spaziergang machen
dinge die wir vorher nicht getan haben
die rivas sind immer noch begeisterte
fans anna maria habt ihr auto früher
kostenlos an einer öffentlichen säule in
der nähe ihres büros aufgetankt und
musste nur einen jahresbeitrag von 100
franken zahlen aber es ist okay für sie
dass sie heute sowohl für das aufladen
als auch für das anhalten bezahlen muss
[Musik]
es war mein 65 der geburtstag als ich in
rente gehen konnte und so wurde das an
richtig symbolisches datum 65 jahren
ruhestand elektroauto
für mich war klar dass ich ein auto
wollte dass es mir möglich macht ein
bisschen herum zu führen
und zu fotografieren
aber mit etwas das die umwelt nicht
belastet
und dann nachdem ich die solarzellen
angebracht hatte dachte ich daran eine
art zapfsäule auf dem dach anzubringen
auch das war etwas das perfekt passt
paul nicole kaufte im dezember einen
nissan leaf das meistverkaufte
elektroauto der welt es war das neueste
modell und noch nicht auf dem markt das
auto wurde sechs monate später geliefert
der verkäufer versprach ihm eine
reichweite von etwa 380 kilometern
[Musik]
es fiel mir etwas zu sein das vom
hersteller vom verkäufer garantiert
wurde obwohl dieses auto unbekannt war
von geheimnissen umhüllt
weil man es noch nicht anfassen und
ausprobieren konnte und man einfach den
zusagen vertrauen musste
die autonomie eines elektroautos hängt
von vielen faktoren die geschwindigkeit
benutzung von klimaanlage oder heizung
häufiges beschleunigen und bergauffahren
verbrauchen energie und verringern die
kilometer die man zurücklegen kann um
einiges paul ist sich dessen bewusst
aber erlebt fast sofort eine bittere
enttäuschung
[Musik]
ich bin nach mal panzer und zurück
gefahren 196 km ich bin auch zu hause
angekommen aber ich hatte angst stecken
zu bleiben
[Musik]
ich habe an mich angeschrieben
meiner meinung nach ist das
ich will nicht sagen betrug das ist
vielleicht etwas übertrieben aber
die informationen stimmen nicht
es sind informationen die dem interesse
des verbrauchers widersprechen
in dem brief schreibt paul auch
im laufe der monate haben sie ihre
parameter teilweise korrigiert aber für
diejenigen die wie ich im jahr 2017
gekauft haben waren sie nicht bekannt
missen antwortet
die daten in unserer broschüre werden in
einem labor gemessen sie können
natürlich nicht mit den angaben des
kunden verglichen werden
die antwort des herstellers stellt
unseren fahrer überhaupt nicht zufrieden
aber wie konnte das passieren
die daten des verbrauchs und damit der
autonomie stimmen überein die
angegebenen daten und das was der
verbraucher jeden tag erlebt die gesetze
wurden so geschrieben dass sie die
bauherren in jeder erdenklichen weise
begünstigen jetzt haben sich die gesetze
geändert im september wurden
vorschriften eingeführt die versuchen
die daten der realität anzunähern aber
es wird immer eine lücke geben und das
gilt sowohl für normale autos als auch
für elektroautos
derzeit gibt nissan nach den neuen
normen 389 kilometer autonomie in der
stadt und 270 kilometer im umland an das
heißt wenn man auch außerhalb der stadt
führt
[Musik]
der automobilclub tcs geht davon aus
dass die tatsächliche autonomie im
stadtverkehr bei durchschnittlich 234 km
wären zitat die autonomie bei einer
geschwindigkeit von 120
stundenkilometern
buchstäblich ausfällt
[Musik]
in unserer umfrage hat sich die hälfte
der elektroauto fahrer an den
gebrauchtmarkt gewarnt
rechtsanwalt garbani hat sich dagegen
für einen neuwagen im opel ampera
entschieden
sie kosten mehr hat das stimmt sie
kosten ein bisschen mehr aber ich habe
sonnenkollektoren auf meinem dach
installiert ich fahre praktisch umsonst
und verschmutze nichts
und in diesen sechs monaten bin ich mehr
als 10.000 kilometer gefahren ich habe
öffentliche ladestationen für maximal 20
franken benutzt
ich lade selten an denselben sollen auf
heute ist es eine ausnahme weil ich
keine zeit hatte es aufzuladen und dann
lasse ich es stehen und fahren zurück
ins büro
da haben wir es
funktioniert auch dieses mal nicht die
karte wird nicht gelesen
[Musik]
marco garbani hatte vor drei monaten
darauf hingewiesen dass die motive ins
rango in der nähe seines büros nicht
funktioniert und sich vergewissert dass
das recht an seiner karte heute wieder
das gleiche der anwalt ruft wieder bei
der hotline lang
also sie bezahlen die aufladung es gibt
möglicherweise einen fehler chip
er hat mir geraten eine app auf dem
handy zu nutzen
aber ich gehöre nicht mehr zur
elektronischen generation
wenn ich also das herunterladen von apps
vermeiden kann ist es mir immer noch
lieber dinge wie die karte in der hand
zu halten anstatt mit dem handy zu
spielen
[Musik]
wenn ich eine reise mache die über die
autonomie meines kleinen elektroautos
hinaus geht schaue ich in einer app nach
wo die säulen an meiner route sind
die sollen die ich in zürich findet
kann ich sie auch reservieren dass ich
sicher sein kann dass sie frei ist wenn
ich ankomme
und dann gibt es entlang des weges all
die anderen die ich auswählen kann
ich habe einen peugeot ion gekauft ein
kleines e auto mit vier sitzen und
seiner recht begrenzten autonomie
ich bin als zweitwagen war damit in der
stadt herum doch kurze ausflüge und vor
allem kann ich damit vors haus fahren
wenn ich einkaufstüten dabei hat
[Musik]
computerjournalist und besitzer eines
opel mokka mit benzinmotor hat sich vor
sechs monaten ein gebrauchtes
elektroauto für 12000 franken gekauft
und 760 franken für eine kleine wall box
in heim- ladegerät ausgegeben
eine volle ladung eines elektroautos
also etwa 100 km autonomie kostet mich
weniger als drei franken wenn ich nachts
zu hause aufladen
wenn ich aber 100 kilometer mit meinem
benzin auto fahren muss
sagt mir die konkrete abrechnung dass
man verbrauch bei etwa 11 franken liegt
in diesen monaten habe ich etwa 300
franken allein an energie gespart der
vergleich bezieht sich hier auf kleine
elektro und mittlere benzinautos aber im
allgemeinen ist das e auto günstig oder
nicht
es ist schwierig in der schweiz über
elektroautos in bezug auf die
einsparungen zu sprechen das ist nicht
das ziel das man vor augen hat aber man
spart schon es kommt darauf an mit
welchem auto man es vergleicht
ihr tcs hat verschiedene autos der
gleichen kategorie verglichen
elektroautos sind in der anschaffung
teurer als verbrenner
eine tatsache die sich in allen
kategorien wie definiert stadtautos
kleinwagen autos der oberklasse die
allerdings etwas teurer sind
es stimmt dass e-autos im tessin weniger
kfz-steuer kosten
und die energie zum aufladen kostet zwei
drittel weniger als fossile brennstoffe
aber es ist ratsam eine wall box zu
hause zu installieren die auf den
einsatz eines elektrikers fordert kann
man sich unter diesen bedingungen eine
kilometerleistung vorstellen nach den
berechnungen des tcs müssten mit einem
elektrischen stadtauto zu viele
kilometer zurückgelegt werden bei einem
mittelklassewagen ist die grenze nach
etwa 180 tausend kilometern erreicht
während heinz elektroautos bei gleicher
leistung deutlich konkurrenzfähiger sind
nach 88 1000 kilometern beläuft sich die
ersparnis schon auf über 7000 franken
[Musik]
weder monticelli hier treffen sich die
teslas einmal im monat alles glückliche
besitzer eines hochwertigen super
technologischen autos das in dieser
tankstelle schnell wieder aufgeladen
werden kann
20 minuten für 50 prozent der batterie
ich komme aus kino bin lehrer im
ruhestand
die dornier angestellter ich arbeite in
der telekommunikation techniker
taxifahrer videofilmer
wie viele teslas gibt es im tessin
etwa 80 eigentlich gibt es fast 300
teslas im tessin
die die einen tesla kaufen treffen eine
nicht ökonomische wahl die er ökologisch
orientiert ist für viele ist es aber
auch eine image sache
tesla hat ein ausgedehntes netz
unbegrenzte kostenloser ladestationen
für alle die das auto bis mitte
september dieses jahres gekauft haben
und es gibt einige die das für eine
aufregende reise genutzt haben ich bin
zum nordkap gefahren vom liga- netto zum
nordkap
[Musik]
ein ladegerät funktionierte nicht und
ich musste in ein hotel gehen wo ich
fünf euro bezahlen musste 8000 kilometer
für fünf euro ich meine fünf franken
[Musik]
auf dem pariser autosalon wurde auch der
neueste tesla vorgestellt das modell 3
ein auto das kleiner ist als seine
vorgänger und für das schon
hunderttausende vorbestellungen aus der
ganzen welt eingegangen sind die ersten
auslieferungen in europa sind für
nächstes jahr geplant der preis für das
basismodell soll in den usa bei 35.000
dollar laden also rund 35.000 fremden
und ist damit konkurrenzfähig mit
mittelklassewagen und dann viele high
end autos also teurer man könnte sagen
die prestigeträchtigsten autohersteller
die das geschäft wittern heizen die
motoren
wir werden bis 20 22 10 fahrzeug
einführen sie werden alle voll
elektrisch sein dies ist das erste von
mercedes es wird noch sechs weitere für
die cue serie geben wir haben also eine
breite strategie bei daimler haben wir
klar entschieden dass die e mobilität
eine der säulen der zukunft ist
wir haben den preis für dieses auto noch
nicht bekannt gegeben ich glaube er wird
sehr wettbewerbsfähig sein auch im
vergleich zu den verbrennern ohne zu
vergessen dass auch der smart der vor 20
jahren geborene kleinwagen ab 2020 nur
noch elektrisch fahren wird neben den
neusten versionen konnten wir auf der
messe auch einen futuristischen und
lustigen prototypen bewundern
ich glaube es ist eine gute idee einen
elektrischen smart in der stadt zu
fahren die sind sehr praktisch in der
stadt ohne co2 emissionen zu fahren
macht absolut sinn
nach dem enthusiastischen
mercedes-manager hier ein enttäuschter
direktor der renommiertesten
italienischen automobilzeitschrift
das auto steht vor einem epochalen
paradigmenwechsel und der hätte nicht
begonnen wenn nicht im september vor
drei jahren das diesel geld gekommen
wäre plötzlich wurde uns eine ganze
reihe von mängeln und problemen bewusst
die diese branche schon immer hatte wie
zum beispiel die tatsache dass die
kontrolleure gleichzeitig auch
diejenigen waren die kontrolliert wurden
das war der wendepunkt diejenigen die
das geld hatten einen paradigmenwechsel
zu vollziehen tun das indem sie sich der
elektrizität zu wenden
nicht umsonst fallen viele der auf der
messe präsentierten neuheiten in die
kategorie premium also teuer
wir sehen den audi e tron wir sehen den
mercedes wir sehen den tesla das sind
autos die von 80000 bis 100000 euro
aufwärts kosten werden autos die billig
sind und eine hohe autonomie bieten kann
man an den fingern einer hand abzählen
der audi e tron zum beispiel hat einen
700 kilo schwere batterie das ist halb
so schwer wie ein normales auto sollte
es einmal leistungsstärkere und kleinere
batterien geben können sie in kleineren
und billigeren autos eingesetzt werden
im moment sind die anreize wie die dinge
liegen von großer bedeutung das e auto
ist aktuell ein geschäft das durch das
geld der gemeinschaft unterstützt wird
damiano boni glaubte schon vor fast 20
jahren an elektroautos als in mendrisio
das pilotprojekt des verbandes zur
förderung von vl leichten
elektrofahrzeugen gestartet wurde mit
dem projekt das sich dann auf den ganzen
kanton ausdehnte und auf öffentliche
gelder und private förderungen setzte
erreichten die anreize die hälfte des
auto wärters
[Musik]
damiano zeigt uns heute stolz seinen
batteriebetriebenen peugeot ein 18 jahre
altes relikt
22.000 franken kostete das auto damals
ungefähr und mit der prämie habe ich am
ende 11 tausend franken bezahlt es blieb
noch das problem der batterie mieter
werden die batterien wurden nicht mit
dem fahrzeug verkauft und sie kosteten
200 franken pro monat und es gibt noch
ein weiteres problem die frage wie man
das auto wieder aufladen konnte
hier sehen sie jetzt eine säule die
wirklich zu einer ersten generation
gehört
gehen wir mal zurück ins jahr 2000 da
hatte fast niemand ein elektroauto
jeder wollte es ausprobieren um zu sehen
wie es funktioniert und so weiter aber
als es hieß dass die maximale reichweite
bei 80 kilometern liegt und das problem
aber auf laden gibt wurde der
durchschnittsnutzer sofort wieder
entmutigt
wir entscheiden uns stattdessen für eine
spritztour es sieht aus wie ein
spielzeugauto
ich schalte das fahrzeug ein indem ich
den schlüssel drehen wenn es klick macht
kann ich fahren wenn ich rückwärts
fahren will habe ich diesen knopf wenn
ich vorwärts fahren will ist es derselbe
knopf es gibt die bremse wie es sie
früher bei autos gab heizung und das ist
alles
[Musik]
2015 endete das vl brühe polina weil
tessin in einer volksabstimmung die
finanzierung neuer umwelt anreize durch
eine höhere stranzl steuer ablehnte
eine entscheidung die damiano nicht
aufhielt da er auch das vorletzte modell
des nissan leaf besetzt was ihnen am
meisten stört ist dass die tarife für
öffentliche ladestationen kürzlich
erhöht wurden
einmal aufladen kann hier sieben oder
acht franken kosten zu hause käme ich
vielleicht auf ein viertel dieses
betrags
also was sie gerne hätten wären etwas
niedrigere tarife
genau vor allem die parkgebühren
außerhalb der zentren die machen für
mich keinen sinn
[Musik]
da die parkplätze außerhalb der zentren
wie auch hier kostenlos oder teilweise
kostenlos sind sehe ich nicht ein warum
man für das parken gebühren erheben
sollte wenn die kosten pro
kilowattstunde strom schon so hoch sind
[Musik]
nico grafik designer lebt in collina
d'oro einen der wenigen städte die
bereits anreize für den kauf von
elektroautos geschaffen haben seit
diesem jahr können die einwohner
zuschüsse von bis zu 3000 franken
erhalten leider hatte laurent seinen e
golf bereits gekauft
aber er fühlt sich nicht betrogen
nein ehrlich gesagt nicht natürlich habe
ich das auto zum falschen zeitpunkt
gekauft aber ich glaube der trend wird
immer so sein
so kann es aber nicht weitergehen der
verkehr der immer mehr zunimmt wir
verschmutzen immer mehr die
schadstoffwerte werden immer höher
man muss wirklich anfangen über eine
lösung nachzudenken
fühlen sie sich nicht wie ein kleiner
tropfen im meer
absolut ja ich fühle mich wie ein
tropfen im meer aber viele kleine
tropfen können etwas bewirken
laurent weist darauf hin dass auch die
öffentliche säule die im zentrum von
collina d'oro steht probleme hat auch
sie kann die karte nicht lesen
mir wurde gesagt ich soll es mit der app
starten und die app funktioniert ja nur
mit einem handy wenn also das
telefonnetz keine verbindung herstellt
können wir den ladevorgang nicht starten
in faido am fuße der auffahrt zum
gotthardtunnel treffen wir franco buhe
den geschäftsführer von energie besitzer
der defekten motiv sollen nach dem
zweiten fall wollen wir verstehen worauf
die ausfälle zurückzuführen sind
die probleme hängen mit einem kabel
zusammen an dass ein kartenlesegerät
angeschlossen war ein eher unbedeutendes
kabel das einen falschen kontakt hatte
ein problem also dass auch schwer
herauszufinden war weil es manchmal
funktioniert wird man manchmal nicht ich
kann ihnen aber versichern dass das
kabel ausgetauscht wurde wenn die sollen
jetzt voll funktionsfähig sind
für den geschäftsführer von energy dass
die zehn wichtigsten
stromversorgungsunternehmen des kantons
umfasst
sind dass ereignisse die passieren
können vor allem wenn man das größte
öffentliche stromnetz des tessins
verhalten
im moment haben wir etwa 80
ladestationen im tessin
die meisten davon sind normale
ladesäulen
hier hinter mir haben wir eine
schnellere sonne
die
normalen säulen laden bis zu 100
kilometer reale autonomie für jede
stunde aufladung die schnelle säule lädt
in weniger als einer halben stunde etwas
mehr auf den fahrern die die hohe
gebühren erhöhung kritisieren
antwortet der manager von der
bund hat beschlossen die initiative den
privatpersonen zu überlassen und weder
die ladesäulen noch den kauf der
fahrzeuge zu subventionieren weil der
seinen marktanteil weiter markt ist kann
es sich niemand leisten almosen zu geben
einerseits vergibt der bund keine
subventionen andererseits versucht das
tessin neue anreize zu schaffen
25 millionen franken für den kauf von
elektroautos familie und eine halbe
million um die installation von
ladestationen zu hause und am
arbeitsplatz zu fördern ein widerspruch
der bund hat unterstützung für die
elektromobilität angekündigt will aber
keine direkten beiträge zahlen
der kanton nimmt er eine ergänzende
rolle ein um den prozess zu
beschleunigen die autos auszutauschen um
wenigstens teilweise die preisdifferenz
für den potenziell interessierten
benutzer zu kompensieren
eine bescheidene maßnahme die vielleicht
1000 autos finanzieren wird der staat
zahl 2000 franken wenn der hersteller
den gleichen betrag gewährt es ist
illusorisch zu glauben dass das wirklich
dazu beitragen wird die verkehrsbedingte
luftverschmutzung zu verringern
wenn dieser anreiz erfolgreich ist kann
er später wiederholt werden wenn die
marktbedingungen das erfordern
es soll vor allem auch der versuch sein
neue nutzer hoffentlich auch jüngere
leute an das e-auto heranzuführen
wenn wir uns auf diese 1000 autos
beschränken ist die auswirkung auf die
luftqualität natürlich zu
vernachlässigen
welche mittel werden dann von den
herstellern zur verfügung stehen wir
haben mercedes gefragt
wenn eine regierung beschließt die
anzahl der e fahrzeuge zu erhöhen ist
das eine gute idee sieht als marke
glauben wir dass wir autos produzieren
müssen die die kunden kaufen weil sie
einfach schön sind aber
wenn man in diese richtung geht werden
die lokalen einzelhändler entscheiden
was zu tun ist
drei von sechs menschen die wir
getroffen haben haben eine
photovoltaikanlage ebenso viele haben
ein gebrauchtes elektroauto gekauft nur
einer hat die entscheidung ein wenig
bereut will es aber nicht verkaufen
bis auf eine ausnahme benutzen alle noch
ein herkömmliches auto für lange fahrten
oder urlauber
ein bild in dem die farbe der
ökologische zeitgeist wird die regierung
mit ihrem manöver anderer autofahrer
abfangen
jetzt wo neue interessante modelle auf
den markt kommen
die wetten sind offen
[Musik]